hash tables are kind of the next logical
step after learning about arrays and
linked lists
if you're unfamiliar with hash tables i
find it's really helpful to start by
talking about the problem being solved
here
basically hash tables are a way of
storing a bunch of crap and then being
able to access it later quickly using a
key so the first thing you might be
thinking is hey wait that sounds exactly
like an array and that's a good
observation
let's look at inserting a bunch of crap
into an array so i dump some items into
this array here
and we can access the items later using
the index of the array so the important
thing to note here is that the key is
the index
but the problem is that this is entirely
dependent on the insertion order if i
had inserted them in a different order
their indices or their keys would be
different and the other problem is that
if you don't know the index or the key
ahead of time you have to search the
array to find what you're looking for
instead let's try to compute our own
array index using something called a
hash function and this can be literally
anything but let's do something super
stupid and we'll take the name and i'll
just take the length of the name because
i said super stupid but you can easily
see now where they go in the array and
it doesn't matter what order i insert
them in because we computed our own
array index
and we can look up things really quickly
if i want to see if hermes is in the
table well the length is 5 so i check
that spot in the array and boom nothing
there super fast and easy but there's
some obvious problems here like what
happens when i try to insert kiff well
that has three letters and that spot is
already taken by fry so we need to
figure out how to work around this
in a hash table when two separate keys
end up hashing to the same index you
have what's called a hash collision
and that's perfectly normal they can be
mitigated against by using a better hash
function our example used an extra
stupid one that you'd never use in
reality and there's plenty of great ones
out there but no matter how random your
hash function is you're still screwed
because of basic probability and you're
likely to get collisions anyway so just
embrace it and learn to deal with it and
there are a couple major approaches that
are used in this case the first of which
is chaining or separate chaining and the
concept is simple
instead of allowing you just to store
one item at each bucket in the array or
the hash table here's our hash table
again
instead you make the bucket hold a whole
bunch of things crazy i know for example
you can make each of these buckets its
own linked list capable of holding a
whole bunch of crap doesn't have to be a
link list either there's other options
you could make this like a dynamic array
that'd work too or really whatever fancy
pants data structure you want the
important thing to note here is that
each bucket can contain a whole bunch of
items instead of just one the most
obvious downside to this approach then
is that when you're doing a lookup and
you hash to that bucket you're going to
have to sift through all the crap in
that bucket to find what you're looking
for which probably won't be a lot but
who knows
the other generally used approach is
something called open addressing which
is a fancy way of saying that you're
going to keep trying new buckets until
you find a free one so in our hash table
if this bucket is used let's say your
two keys hash to the same bucket again
you just move on to another bucket using
some predetermined approach and for the
predetermined approaches well there's a
few basic ones like linear probing which
literally just means incrementing the
index by some fixed amount that's really
really easy
there's a few other well-known scanning
sequences like quadratic and double
hashing which are somewhat
self-explanatory in quadratic probing
you'd increase the array index by some
non-linear value and in double hashing
your spacing is determined by a second
hashing function there's a whole bunch
of others with kind of silly names which
we're not going to go into let's just
cover the basics of how this works
so yeah you've got your collision
resolution scheme and they have various
upsides and downsides for example
with open addressing and linear probing
lookups are often slightly faster than
most other approaches due to cache
effects watch the video on memory cache
locality and why arrays are fast it
should be pretty self-evident but one
thing you can probably guess is that as
the table fills up the performance
starts to degrade pretty badly as you
search larger chunks of the table the
various approaches have their upsides
and downsides for our purposes it's
sufficient to understand that there are
two main schemes for resolving
collisions either a bucket holds a
single key value pair and the collisions
are resolved by moving to another bucket
or we make each bucket hold a whole
bunch of key value pairs shocking what
you've probably noticed at this point is
that there's another problem lurking in
the shadows here which is that the hash
table can be infinitely big
you have to set some fixed size and as
you fill up the table no matter what
collision resolution scheme you use
you'll get collisions and your
performance will degrade depending on
your resolution scheme now there's a
more proper name for how full the table
is which is load factor and it's a
problem you have to keep your eye on
because as the load factor increases
performance decreases
sometimes dramatically after reaching
certain thresholds
basically your approach at this point
assuming you want to keep allowing new
items is to increase the max size of the
table by allocating a larger underlying
array and then re-inserting every single
item into that new array from the old
one and you can do this all at once say
once you've passed a certain threshold
you can decide screw it we're building
the whole thing from scratch or you can
do it incrementally so there isn't a
sudden slowdown but the gist of it is
that at some point you got to make the
table bigger to accommodate more items
and ideally you want to do this before
the table gets too full now if your
question is when do we decide to do that
well a common load factor is about 0.75
so when the table is about three
quarters full it expands you can choose
any threshold you want basically it
boils down to being a trade-off between
not using excessive memory and not
tanking performance sparser hash tables
waste memory but operations are snappy
whereas much fuller ones don't waste
much memory but operations could be
slower and slower so now that we've
talked about hash tables what exactly
are associative arrays dictionaries and
all that jazz often you'll see these
references especially in higher level
languages are these hash tables or what
how do they relate to each other the
short answer is some people group these
all together as mostly the same thing
and it's probably harmless to do so i
mean the practical applications are
generally the same but that'll rile up
the pedantic people so let's dive in a
bit here so there's something called an
abstract data type which is essentially
an abstract description of how something
is supposed to look and act like if i
look up an associative array it's an
abstract data type that defines
precisely how they're supposed to work
you can see here the operations are
listed you can add reassign remove and
look up items using keys or key value
pairs but
it tells me nothing about how it's
supposed to be implemented like for
realsies using actual code it only
roughly tells me what operation should
be available and the restrictions on
them if i were to say describe a vehicle
abstractly here's my abstract vehicle
and it's supposed to have some sort of
engine two or more wheels and seat two
or more passengers pretty vague a car
might be the most common implementation
of my abstract vehicle but it doesn't
necessarily rule out other
implementations they just might have
other trade-offs or just outright be
kind of stupid but they still meet the
vehicle checklist so associative arrays
and dictionaries they're the abstract
description of a kind of data structure
and hash tables are a specific data
structure often used as an
implementation for associative arrays or
dictionaries so let's talk a little bit
about advantages and disadvantages of
hash tables now we'll mostly compare
these with arrays and linked lists since
we covered those previously but hash
tables are kind of just a great
all-purpose data structure i mean
there's a reason why languages like
javascript python go and many many many
other languages have built-in language
level support for associative arrays
they're just useful as hell most
operations are in the average case
pretty fast insertions deletions and
lookups are order one constant time
contrast that to arrays and linked lists
which are fast at some of these
operations slow at others and it all
depends exactly where in the array or
linked list you're doing things so the
disadvantages now first off hash tables
are fast all of the operations are order
one but if you recall from the video on
big o notation the big o running time of
an algorithm isn't everything for
example on this blog post by scott
meyers the author of effective c plus
should you be using something instead of
what you should use instead scott gives
some great examples of just straight up
linear searches on arrays beating hash
table lookups for small numbers of
entries and remember when we talked
about rehashing so although the average
time for insertion is order 1 like all
your insertions are chugging along at a
nice speed and then it is of course
possible to hit that path where you need
to expand and rehash the whole table
so the cost of calling functions could
be inconsistent if that's important to
you there are some other downsides too
like there's no inherent ordering in a
hash table so you can't iterate things
in any given order so if you require
things to be in a consistent and
reproducible order hash tables aren't a
great fit i'll avoid babbling about
theoretical concerns which are super
unlikely in practice especially in game
development like uneven hash
distributions which is like say your
hash function hashes a bunch of crap to
the same spot over and over again i mean
it's possible so i'll mention it but
let's not lose sleep over this finally
let's talk about how to use them and
what better way to actually go through
and show you if you've been following
the channel for a while i've built a few
games at this point mostly showcasing
how you can get really far with really
simple approaches and we can go poke
around the code a bit on github looking
at some of the use cases for associative
arrays here's a good first example in a
lot of these projects i have this entity
class that holds a bunch of components
stuff like rendering physics that stuff
if you've used unity it's basically a
poor man's game object system anyway i
use an associative array here for the
components there's often quite a few
lookups for components by name and
although we iterate the components every
frame to update them the order doesn't
matter here in the entity manager i keep
a list of all the entities in existence
in the game those are all just in a big
array but i keep a separate associative
array for quick lookups since there may
be hundreds or thousands of entities and
i often want to look up entities by name
here's another quick and easy one the
finite state machine has an associative
array of states mostly because i refer
to states by name there's not that many
you could just do it with an array but
the syntax for lookups is easy so i go
with associative arrays instead and
finally here's the spatial hashgrid code
from a while back and this is a great
example because originally i used an
associated array but here we're using
specifically a map in the code in github
as the basis for the spatial hashgrid
and this was an enormous improvement
over doing it the stupid naive way but
at the same time this is a fantastic
example of how these kind of data
structures are great as a general
purpose pretty good solution but can
often be beaten out by a custom data
structure which is exactly what we did
in this case to squeeze out even more
performance so in general hash tables
associate arrays dictionaries and
whatever i just kind of match them
together sue me so these along with
dynamic arrays kind of make up like 99
of the data structures in the games i've
been implementing i tend to just default
to an array if i'm going to be iterating
things a lot but not searching for
specific items often
otherwise an associated array is my
other go-to data structure if i need to
do a bunch of lookups but not iterate
otherwise at this point i need to start
thinking seriously about being smarter
about either my architecture or the data
structure i'm using i hope this was
helpful until next time cheers